hello I'm gonna stylish a critic guy
remember so you don't have to well
you've heard me go on and on about the
secret of NIMH praising it as one of my
favorite movies and many would agree
that it is a good play good characters
good story good animation more than
enough material for both kids and adults
it's an awesome piece of awesome
awesomeness and well in my other videos
I've talked about the strengths of all
those elements this time I wish to focus
on something different the themes of the
story because one question that keeps
popping up from people who have seen the
movie is what the hell does it mean most
of the story is pretty straightforward
but then it takes a turn that seems to
split people right down the middle
that being the absence of clarifying
what the stone is and why it has
supernatural powers some say it's
vagueness projects the film into being a
classic others say it's a do SS machina
that forces unneeded Disney magic into
another wise good film wars have been
started brothers turned against brother
it's torn this world apart and yes I
have a theory as well about what the
messages and ideas of this movie can
possibly be about it probably goes
without saying but this is going to be
very heavy on the spoilers so if you
haven't seen the movie yet you probably
should before going any further or the
shorter way of putting it
spoilers with that said let's dive right
in and take a look at its core I think
the essential story is about science
versus nature some might say that's
pretty obvious and even a little too
simplistic but hear me out
the rants of name started out as any
ordinary rat until they were
experimented on and became genetically
altered making them more intelligent
than any other animal outside of man I
looked upon the word under the cage door
and understood them
we had become intelligent
once they escaped their goal is to keep
feeding their intelligence and continue
to grow
making discovery after discovery and
becoming more and more aware that
knowledge is power but they realize the
more powerful they become the more they
have responsibility to that power and
all the rats know that a major change is
on the horizon one that will define who
they are and where their power is going
to leave them as the movie begins we see
the rats are stealing electricity from
the farmers
conducting their own experiments and
learning how to grow the rats believe
that they might now be smart enough to
create their own resources and on top of
that morality starts to creep into their
consciousness Cleve I'm stealing it's
wrong to take electricity from the phone
many now think it is wrong to steal the
electricity and if a colony growing in
intelligence and power is going to
survive they need a strong moral Center
and this is a perfect place to start
this is where the focus of many of the
arguments in the movie begin some think
it's a good idea to move away and
harness their own energy others like a
rat named Jenner see no reason to leave
when everything they need is at their
fingertips the thorn valley plan is the
aspiration of idiots and dreamers Jenner
could be seen as a OneNote villain for
this except for the fact that many
growing empires have displayed these
characteristics countless times in the
past he represents the fear of change
and the resistance of ethical
responsibility the need to keep the
world of comfort and power at any cost
and we see in great detail that he will
go to any cost killing their leader
fighting anyone who gets in his way and
attempting to gain even more power to
cement his status so the science in this
science versus nature story is obviously
the experiments conducted on the rat and
the experiments they conduct to grow
themselves as a result of it the nature
is the choices they make with it
discovering what is best for survival
and creating a world for them to evolve
in a world of peace and security that
they know comes from morally responsible
choices these are choices that
politicians the media and the common
people make every day as our technology
in so many fields continues to grow and
as a result we struggle to keep up with
what is the responsible and ethical way
to use them we can no longer do as we
act
no too much no that's all fine and good
but that still raises the question what
is the significance of the stone the
stone in the movie is said to only have
power when someone shows courage of the
heart and in the end is mrs. Brisby who
of course uses it to save her family
after nearly sacrificing herself for
them but it's never explained who
created it where it comes from how it
works why it works or even really what
it is well that brings in another
element that's often overlooked in the
science versus nature battle the unknown
the circumstances we can't explain the
questions we can't answer that element
as well we'll always be in humanity
struggle whether we call parts of this
unknown element God spirituality or
merely the unexplained there's always
going to be occurrences that neither
science nor nature will have the factual
answers to that's 6 cents those
unexplained feelings that pull you in
certain directions heck you could even
tie it into the mysteries of the past
and the fears of the future which are
both talked about often in this bill so
the stone can be defined as well
anything that can be defined but what
makes the film so interesting is that
this 2 plays a major role in moving
forward how we treat the unknown and
when it's best to be resistant or
embracing and in this case the kind
embracing heart of our hero is what
pulls through the stone even manages to
burn her when she touches it but
something still calls her to it she
still follows an unknown urge that she
believes is still the right thing to do
and following that instinct ultimately
leads her to saving the day God who
thought he's very bad the stone has a
power we needs that so it appears it's a
three-way battle science versus nature
versus the unknown and you can't act
like you haven't seen people who rally
behind one of these sides to an extreme
that science is always correct our
nature is always correct or even the
unknown is always correct by the time
the movie is over it isn't one element
that everyone has to rally behind in
order to move forward it's a balance of
all of them science nature and the
unknown all three are needed to pursue a
strong prosperous future not one is left
out the addition of the unknown element
is what makes this so fascinate
though as it's not often seen as one of
the fighting components with science and
nature if anything it's often the
problem we want to make the unknown
known and we want to use one of these
elements to figure it out but here it's
not shown as one of the problems it's
shown as one of the answers that the
unknown when treated with careful
kindness and humble intentions can be
just as powerful as extreme and vision
or logical reasoning you can unlock any
door if you only have the key and that's
why I think the film is so good it has
all the factors of film needs to be
strong great characters story and so
forth but it also leaves it open for
possibilities it gives enough detail but
leaves just enough vagueness that there
is room for interpretation but now am I
honestly saying this is what the writers
and the director of this film had in
mind when they put this movie together
probably not I don't know what their
original mindset was and I think it's
very possible I'm reading more into it
than what was originally intended but
that doesn't mean these themes and ideas
still can't come from it that's why
movies are art you can look at a film
and get a totally different outlook than
somebody else look at triumph of the
will the Nazi propaganda film I'm sure
the makers of that thought it was an
inspiring uplifting look at the future
but the rest of us were scared shitless
seeing it as a terrifying nightmare of
what could happen if we don't fight back
but just because an artist has a certain
interpretation of their piece doesn't
mean that's the interpretation you
should have it's all in the eye of the
beholder and whether or not the theories
and outlooks I have on this film are the
same as the filmmakers these theories
and outlooks can still be connected
because these are the themes that I see
in the film and I believe their themes
that other people should consider too
they caution us of what it means to
evolve and what limitations and
expectations we should consider anytime
there is a technological boom that will
launch a culture into achieving a new
kind of power which obviously has
occurred many times in the past and will
continue to occur many times in the
future this story will be relevant I
don't think it's the first story to deal
with the subject but I think it is one
of the more unique it uses a family film
to simplify the idea
that is get it down to its most basic
form that way even kids can look at and
understand what's going on and adults
can interpret it as what is still going
on today and what will most likely still
be going on in the future it sucks you
in gets you invested and forces you to
look at certain ideas from a different
point of view which is more than I can
say for a certain piece of
spin-offs unless Eric Idle as the
villain is supposed to represent how in
the creation of an artwork the insight
plays a casual role in bringing about
action significant for realizing
particular aesthetic properties but come
on that's obvious whatever you take out
of the film this is my interpretation
feel free to agree or create your own
but either way the film deserves to be
looked at and discussed by both children
and adults and in terms of whether or
not the film will ever have a theory
that the majority of people will agree
on well maybe in the end that's the
film's own little secret
next I'll explain how Care Bears is
related to our current economic downward
spiral or maybe I should just out there
I'm gonna stop so credit guy remembered
so you don't have to